photos what do we have over our wii golf
free are we gonna be inflicted with that
golf course oh you know you can't have
too many photographs of golf courses
particularly on Puget Sound tongue but
number three we're starting with
Charleston South Carolina because about
10,000 people joined hands in the so
called unity chain an Arthur Ravenel jr.
bridge at dusk two more in the nine
victims of the Emanuel AME Church
shooting to show solidarity people cross
the bridge from Mount Pleasant and
Charleston and to join hands strawberry
yeah wonderful scenes there our number
to photograph today in new delhi india
yesterday indian Prime Minister Modi
performed yoga on the first ever
international day of yoga an estimated
forty thousand people participated in
the celebrations at rajpath with around
two billion people taking part across
the world you know I see their food and
I'm sure hum I sleep stretching earlier
there we go I don't do this thing this
thing is if I did the Abbey phony but
this isn't phony if I go like this and
go any LD there we go there we go that's
along waiting for you know what I see
though bring up that photo what I see
though is the infamous New Delhi haze
that I've actually read about people
it's not it's move so much worse than it
is in Beijing and people are really
seriously reconsidering whether or not
they raise their children as expats
their new delhi but this brings india
together I mean this was a how many do
you say two billion billion worldwide
and killing in Times Square yes in Paris
New Yorkers okay at number one in
Huntington Beach California 66 surfers
ride the world's largest surfboards to
break the Guinness Book of Records
record for the largest number of surfers
ever to ride a wave on a single
surfboard they waxed the 42-foot
longboard beforehand and enjoyed a solid
12 seconds of wave time the previous
record was 47 in Queensland Australia
every what was said about a decade ago
every single one of them holding a GoPro
now wait did they actually did they ride
away this I'm trying to figure out
what's well was big enough to support
now that kind of looks like surfing they
surfed I mean can you are they wanted
not it would have been like dominoes Wow
yeah fit pretty something I don't even
knew I where did the sweet food come
from the book of records is just insane
and there you know there's there's a
dearth of blanks to be used for first to
make surfboards right so they wasted a
bunch of them for that I'm very confused